good morning good morning to noble forum
and this press conference for the
announcement of this year's Nobel Prize
in Physiology or medicine my name is
Thomas Perlman and
I'm the secretary of the Nobel assembly
I will first read the announcement in
Swedish followed by English and we will
then present some background to the
price and open up for questions
Nobel official Navy Karolinska
Institutet worry dog this list of Nobel
Prize in Physiology or medicine or
tortoise and ho-dong scandalously
gamelon Jeffrey C Hall Michael rosebush
Oh Michael
BB young for the era's objector or
molecular mechanism our son still USC
record is great the Nobel assembly at
Karolinska Institutet has today decided
to award the 2017 Nobel Prize in
Physiology or medicine jointly to
Jeffrey C Hall
Michael rosebush and Michael W young for
their discoveries on molecular
mechanisms controlling the circadian
rhythm here are their three laureates
Jeffrey hall was born in New York and
performed his seminal work at Brandel
Brandeis University he's now retired and
lives in Cambridge in Boston
Michael rosebush is was born in Oklahoma
City and performed his prize-winning
studies also at Brandeis University
where he still on the faculty and
finally Michael yang was born in Miami
and did his work at Rockefeller
University in New York where he saw
where he also remains on the faculty I
will now describe the discoveries behind
this year's award so this year's prize
concerns the circadian rhythm the word
circadian originates from the lat
in Word circa meaning around and Dias
meaning day but in a way it is actually
about astronomy
ever since the emergence of life on
Earth about four billion years ago
evolving life-forms had to adapt to the
rotation of our planet this ability to
prepare for the regular daily
fluctuations is crucial for all
life-forms but how is this possible this
year's Nobel laureates have been
studying this fundamental problem and
solved the mystery of how an inner clock
in most of our cells in our bodies can
anticipate daily fluctuations between
night and day to optimize our behavior
and physiology this existence of an
inner clock was first described already
in the 18th century the French
astronomer de Muro studied the mimosa
plant that opens its leaves towards the
Sun during day that closes at dusk de
Muro asked what would happen if the
plant was exposed exposed to constant
darkness and he found that even then for
several days the leaves continued to
follow the regular 24-hour daily rhythm
in the 20th century it was established
that also other plants and animals
including rodents and humans have their
own biological clocks following the
daily circadian rhythm studies of the
clock in fruit flies show that many
different behaviors are controlled by
the clock fruit flies are really
excellent model organisms for studies of
genetics and in the 1970s a mutation
that affected the flies daily rhythm was
identified the mutated locust was called
period but how did the mutation affect
the internal clock
this year's laureates they wish to peek
inside the clock and figure out how it
actually works
a first breakthrough came in 1984 when
Jeff Hall in collaboration with Michael
rosebush and Michael yang working
independently were able to isolate the
period gene now the scientists could
begin to disentangle the cellular wheels
and cogs of a clock machinery Jeff Hall
and Michael rosebush showed that the
period protein itself was cycling and
peaked during night and was low during
day in 1990 they showed that the period
mRNA also oscillated as shown on this
slide and accumulated several hours
before the period protein these and
other important observations led to a
brilliant idea for how the clock works
by a feedback control mechanism the idea
was shown to be correct and in the next
few slides I will show how it actually
works when the period gene is active
period mRNA is made the period mRNA is
transported to the cell's cytoplasm
where period protein is made when period
protein accumulates the protein moves
into the cell's nucleus with blocks the
activity of its own gene when the gene
is blocked
no more RNA can be made period protein
levels will decrease and gene will no
longer be blocked and the production of
mRNA can start all over again and the
cycle can continue but it remains
unclear how the period protein could
accumulate in the nucleus to inhibit the
gene this problem was solved when
Michael yang discovered the second gene
called timeless that is also critical
for the clock this is shown in this
experiment the top diagram shows how
peered mRNA
is cycling over several days in normal
flies the bottom diagram shows that the
cycling was disrupted when the timeless
gene had been inactivated but how did
the timeless protein affect the period
gene additional experiments showed that
timeless protein bound to the period
protein and together they entered the
cell nucleus where they could inhibit
the period gene
it was also critical to understand how
the speed of the oscillations can be
controlled Michael Young identified yet
another protein called double time or
DBT this Prout how the oscillation can
be adjusted to more closely match a
24-hour cycle Jeff Hall and Michael
rosebush showed that two additional
proteins clock and cycle activated
appeared gene in fruit flies so with all
these groundbreaking discoveries by the
three laureates an elegant feedback
control mechanism for the biological
clock had finally been unraveled we now
recognize that biological clocks
function by these same principles in
other animals including in ourselves in
humans most of our cells in our bodies
have these clocks our inner clock adapts
our physiology to the dramatically
different phases of the day and
regulates many critical functions such
as behavior hormone levels sleep body
temperature and metabolism we do not
feel well when there is a temporary
mismatch between our external
environment and internal biological
clock for example when we experience
jetlag studies have also indicated that
chronic misalignment between our
lifestyles and the clock is associated
with increased risk for various diseases
since the paradigm shifting discoveries
by Hall Ross Bosch and yang
Cajun biology has developed into a
highly dynamic research field with vast
implications for our health and
well-being here they are again
Jeffrey hall Michael Ross Bosh and
Michael Young this is the end of the
presentation and I would now wish to
present our expert panel who would be
happy to respond if there are questions
so at the far end we have professor
Julian Serrat who is a member of the
Nobel Committee in center we have Anna
Weddle who is the chair of the Nobel
Committee and on her side we have
professor Carlos Ibanez who is also a
member of the Nobel Committee so please
if there are any questions please go
ahead
there must be at least one question okay
please go ahead we we are usually not
afraid of calling them about this and I
was able to get hall or Michael Ross
Bosch and Jeffrey hall but I haven't
reached Michael Young so they just got
the news I first got hold of Mike the
rosebush and he was silent and then he
said you are kidding me
is there any other question yeah I'm
there resist go ahead about the dynamics
of this system so if one were to change
the cycle to like six hours instead of
24 hours for humans for somebody or
chicken they're being kept in in very
short it cycles what happens with this
system does it adapt to very short I
think I'll ask are not to respond to
that with them not as you describe six
hours but a little bit and they get
sleep problems we don't know of any
drastic disruptions in humans of the
clock there are of course animal
experiments and if you disrupt the clock
in animals you will get effect on
metabolism and on various physiological
parameters but in humans
it's not really possible to do those
kinds of experiments but are there any
treatments or possible treatments for
sleep disorders that could be based on
this obvious
which is a hormone that is secreted
before we go to sleep and it can also be
used to yeah for those kinds of problems
and some people even use it for jetlag
and also if you're blind for instance
you your rhythm will still be going but
it will be out of sync with the
misaligned it will be free running then
it's it will not be entrained by light
and then you can use similar here's one
question
hello I'm from Chinese media green post
and China Radio International my
understanding of this prize is in
physiology right so can you tell is how
how long have you or how did you find
them and what is their contribution to
mankind Carlos it bothers to respond to
that question how we found them our
mechanism is based on nominations from
different parts of a academic community
and institutions universities other
scientists and then these scientists
have been nominated by these other
members of the Academy community and
research community and then that's how
we found them our work is directed by
the nominations that we get we are aware
of interesting fields but we can only
follow up nominations from the
scientific community and then we
investigate whether the discoveries
merit this prize and that's how we found
them the contribution to humankind is
the discovery of a fundamental mechanism
and the line very important aspects of
physiology how our cells can keep time
did I answer your question
okay Esther here's one question I've got
a one question I'm Fred from China's
national Xinhua news agency regarding to
this discovery do you think this
discovery by the scientists canis can
solve the problems especially that we
encounter in a Nordic countries where
you've got long dark winter days that
people tend to have depression and is it
a this discovery actually shedding
lights to solving the problem to boost
you know people's energy could answer
the question was how this discovery
might solve the problem of how people
cope with extreme dark changes in
darkness or sunlight and I think what it
can do is raise awareness to the
importance of proper sleep hygiene and
the importance of really making certain
that we allow ourselves to you know go
to bed at a an hour that's suitable I
guess from any of us it's around you
know between ten o'clock or so even if
the sun is shining on midsummer day and
it probably helps us to be aware of the
fact that we need to be in a dark
environment to get the best sleep and
that we shouldn't be afraid of using our
alarm clock even when it's the darkest
times of the year so I think what it can
do is help raise awareness okay is there
any else who is interested in not
answering asking a question
bigger bra they go Brown sat through
good for Santiago browser error on a
stroke on the Florida yo as the school
afford row your interview Salman also
the Harlem and in rebuild was Claudia
semana Shanti loss on GUI offset on the
use on the use dilemma worked on the
daughter not the knee in then Gore of
the health then still threat of it
refectories amuse and the food chatter
Gore would improve our car where let me
get over officially or the Maharaja can
haul fish thought mechanism Alfred
hidden - gear or asada clock convenes in
estan are lavoris Eric rotten we
evaluate weekly for weld ammonia
processor okay if there are no more
questions to ask I know many of you are
looking for interviews so we can go
ahead with that
so with that I would like to close this
conference and thank you all for coming
thank you
professor and over them share the Nobel
Committee could you describe to us what
is circadian rhythm so circadian it rise
tremble actin so circus around and day
is BAE and this is the daily rhythm we
have to anticipate and adapt to the
dramatically different conditions during
day and night that arise from the
rotation of the earth the three
laureates what problem have been solved
for a long time that there are a diurnal
circadian rhythms but how it worked
wasn't unknown at all and it was debated
for a long time whether it was a
response to external signals or
something endogenous and they before
they started their work it was
understood that it was endogenous and it
was even understood that single genes
could influence the circadian rhythm but
nothing was known about the mechanism
and there were different hypotheses but
they found out the mechanism that
controls the machinery of the clock so
he turned to the discovery
what were the key findings and who did
what yeah so first of all they studied
they used the fruit fly as a model
system and before their work there has
been a classic experiment by Benson and
Konopka
they had used two fruit fly to ask can
you identify mutants that arise due to
mutations in single genes so that was
sort of a basis before our laureate
started their work and they took
advantage of that because the the gene
wasn't known there were mutant strains
known who had long or short or no rhythm
at all that were known to map to the
same locus so the laureates useless
surprised and went on to isolate the
gene and to determine what gene it was
but that didn't prove the mechanism
either so what they then did was
experiments to understand the function
of the system by this gene and then
several others that they did in
sequential experiments why is circadian
rhythm important so we need the
circadian clock to anticipate the daily
changes not only adapt but anticipate so
it's so there are dramatically different
conditions during day and night and we
need to be very active in the day and
other processes need to take place
during night and evolutionary it's been
a very great advantage to take to use
the only critical lights hours where
minutes of the day for instance if
you're if you're hunting you need to be
active or if you're hunted you need to
run and hide so you need to be prepared
and take advantage of visit one step
before the the environment that's why we
need it it's this kind of clock is it
this is it all ourselves so we know that
most of ourselves have this clock and we
also know we knew before these
discoveries that there is a central
clock in the brain that controls the
rhythm and then later it was found that
it we also have them in other parts of
our body but it's the it's actually the
mechanism that the rory's have elusively
it's an auto regulatory self-sustained
inhibitory feedback in an accessible way
with the penis it's a metaphor one could
use the clock is a metaphor easy but for
the mechanism it's a little bit
difficult but it's an oscillator so you
build up a substance and then when the
substance is there it's return soft it
sounds production and then it can start
over again so it becomes an oscillation
so a negative feedback of its own
synthesis that's the best I can do like
an hourglass when the lower part is full
of sound and it's time to turn around
doesn't really shut off its own
synthesis so it's hard to find something
similar actually so an oscillator and
the mechanism for the oscillator by
shutting off its own synthesis in a
regulated way so it becomes self
sustained autonomous medicine there's a
huge field of chronobiology Crona
medicine it's really exploding it's a
fascinating area but in humans most beta
on specific diseases are so far
correlations so we don't really have the
firm evidence to postulate the circadian
clock does this or that when it comes to
disease there are some examples there
are sleep phase disorders where you
actually have mutations in the core some
of the core clock genes and then you
have a shorter or a longer face and that
causes problems with sleep that's a
solid thing but in humans apart from
that there are lots of correlations
there's more known of course in animal
models where you can disrupt the clock
and then see effects another example is
jet lag of course but that's not really
a disease but that indicates that when
we're misaligned so that our inner clock
does not match or is misaligned to the
environment the clock then we really
feel bad but then of course there's a
lot of interest in trying to understand
if our lifestyle today with social
jetlag has implications for disease and
that's the reality started but so far
mainly correlations
in the wintertime whenever in Sweden and
the darkness how much with one coat how
one shark oh well that's a big question
well what I can say regarding that is
that there's so many things that we need
to understand and also be the core
machinery it's a lot more complex but
the concept is the same but we now know
that there are more factors regulating
and stabilizing there are interconnected
loops and there are mechanisms for
entrainment so you adjust the clock
mechanisms for synchronizing clocks
throughout the body and output
mechanisms so other genes are sort of
hitchhiking on the system and be
controlled by the same mechanism and all
of this is really really dynamic and
we're learning so much
so although these all of these
implication questions what it means for
help that really remains to be familial
down now and they have provided tools
for that by understanding this
mechanisms we now have a way forward to
address these issues
three Americans Mike Wallace he was born
in 1945 worked very closely together
with microtia and they've been working
together since the mid mid 70s and they
are about the same age my precious one
year younger
Paul has retired but my rosebush is very
active there and Michael Young is also
an American he worked independently they
have also had some collaborations but
he's at Rockefeller University he's also
spent a very long career at Rockefeller
and he's still very active finally has
the Nobel Committee you've been able to
reach
yes sir so our secretary-general
professor Thomas Pearlman he has reached
rose fashion hole but he's not been able
to read to Michael Young yet question
what do you think is the best about this
price well it's such a fundamental prize
it's a detailed molecular mechanism but
it explains how we are adapted to the
planets I think it's a very fundamental
thing and it's important for so many
things and it's opened so many questions
been enabled so many questions
you